hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd skin care nerd and lipstick wearer
a lot of you have been asking me to talk more
about the science behind makeup products and
a lot of people have been asking me what lipstick
i've been wearing so i decided to combine the two
in this video if you like nerding out about the
science behind beauty products give this video
a like subscribe to my channel and click the
notification bell so you don't miss any videos
so today i thought i'd talk a little bit about
lipstick science so what goes into a lipstick
i'm going to be talking about the ingredients
that go into a lipstick and the science behind
how they make it work first let's talk about what
her lipstick is i mean we all know what a lipstick
is but let's break it down further lipsticks are
solid sticks that you drag across your skin and
they leave behind a thin layer of color that means
that if you really narrow down to the very basics
a lipstick has to be solid at room temperature
hard enough not to break when you apply some
pressure to it soft enough that'll leave behind a
layer when you drag it across your skin and that
layer has to stay even for a while even though
your lips are one of the places on your face
that moves around the most and it encounters lots
of water so here's what we have in the lipstick
to make this all happen there's a lot of variation
with different brands different types of lipsticks
different finishes but i had to commit to a
percentage to make this diagram so this is just
representative most of the lipstick is made up
of oily substances like waxes waxy paste and oils
this is sometimes called the base of the lipstick
and has to strike a good balance between being
hard enough not to break and soft enough to leave
a nice layer on your lips without too much effort
these oily substances are very water repellent
or hydrophobic which is important because your
lips encounter lots of water from drinking and
from your spit the more solid ingredients in
a lipstick are usually waxes they're sometimes
called structuring agents and they're what gives
a lipstick its solid structure some of the really
common solid wax ingredients that you'll see
are canauba wax candelilla wax beeswax
microcrystalline wax and ozokerite these all
have really high melting points above 60 degrees
or 140 degrees fahrenheit and these keep your
lipsticks mostly solid even when they're on your
lips or in a not too hot handbag generally the
more wax you have in a lipstick the harder it will
be then you have the oils and waxy pastes these
are soft at room temperature and so they'll soften
the overall lipstick so that it'll actually apply
a lot of these are also emollient moisturizers so
they'll keep your lips soft and moisturized there
is a massive range of ingredients that different
lipsticks use for this you have plant oils like
castor oil butters like shea butter fatty esters
like isosteryl isostearate hydrocarbon based
ingredients like polybutene and mineral oil and
silicones like phenol trimethicone oils also give
a shiny finish and so matte lipsticks tend to have
a bit less of these this is why matte lipsticks
often have this reputation of being really drying
and sucking all the moisture out of your lips but
the fact that they have less oils also means that
they tend to last longer on your lips so they form
a harder layer that doesn't move around and slip
around so much an important aspect of the base is
that to get a smooth lipstick it has to dry into
small microscopic crystals not larger chunky ones
so this means the lipstick applies more smoothly
and also it's less prone to breaking because
a small layer of the lipstick can be left behind
without breaking off a large chunk if you have a
grainy textured lipstick this is usually because
the base isn't a great blend another issue that
you might see if you have a bad base mixture is
sweating this is when you see droplets on the
surface of the lipstick and usually it's because
some of the ingredients in the base aren't playing
well together and so some of the oil gets squeezed
out sometimes this happens in hot weather because
the lipstick melts a bit and then re-solidifies
and that process squeezes more oil out then we
have the pigment which is what gives a lipstick
its color one of the important things about
lipstick is that it is on your mouth which means
that it's one of the few cosmetic products that
we will actually end up eating quite a bit of not
as much as fear-mongering places would have you
believe but you do end up eating quite a bit of it
that's the reason why some pigments aren't allowed
in lip products at all or they're only allowed
at certain concentrations the color pigment is
dispersed in the base this means that it doesn't
dissolve in the base but it's ground up into tiny
microscopic pieces that are spread out evenly in
the base and so it looks like it's one continuous
color it's sort of like protein powder and a
protein shake but blended really really well you
get a much nicer looking lipstick if the pigments
are ground up really finely and spread out really
evenly in the base the color additives in a
lipstick are usually in that final section of an
ingredients list that says may contain usually in
a lipstick range the lipstick base stays the same
and it's just the pigments that change that's why
you usually don't see a range of lipsticks that
have both matte and shiny finishes but you usually
see a range that has the same finish and different
colors in there it's relatively easy to change
the pigments in a lipstick around but if you want
to change the finish you have to change the oils
and that means you have to re-jig the whole base
and this is a lot more effort there are lots of
different pigments that you'll see in lipsticks
these are things like inorganic colors like iron
oxide organic colors and their lake versions which
have names like red 7 or red 7 lake there's also
carmine which comes from crushed beetles you'll
see white pigments as well like zinc oxide and
titanium dioxide these make your lipstick more
opaque and so it hides your underlying lip color
and so when you put it on your lips it looks more
like the color in the tube rather than your lips
plus the color in the tube there are also effect
pigments and lipsticks and this is how you get
a glittery or shimmery or pearl or matte finish
for shimmery effects lipsticks use larger
particles than your color pigments would be
so these are things like mica bismuth oxychloride
and pearl these are usually added near the end
of the lipstick making process so you don't
end up mixing it too much and smashing it up
and not having these big flecks anymore with matte
lipstick sometimes there's still a bit too much
oil for it to look properly matte and so there'll
be something added like silica or clay on top of
that you want the lipstick to stay good for longer
and so you have preservatives and antioxidants
lipsticks are generally easier to preserve than
other cosmetic products because they don't contain
water they're very oil-based and so that makes
it a lot harder for mold and bacteria to get a
foothold so usually it's just the surface of
the lipstick that's a bit of a worry and so
preservatives like parabens and phenoxyethanol are
added to stop bacteria mold growing on the surface
but the big problem with oils and butters is that
they tend to go rancid when they're exposed to
oxygen for too long and so antioxidants slow this
from happening you'll see things like vitamin e
bha and bht but the oils and waxes in the base
can still go rancid because if you think about
the lifetime of the lipstick it's relatively long
and oils and waxes on their own do already sort of
smell a bit funny and taste a bit funny like
we don't go around drinking oil for a reason
and so to hide this funny taste and funny smell
we have flavors and fragrances in there as well
there are other optional ingredients in there
as well things like sunscreen actives to give
your lips some sun protection and also active
ingredients like in skin care this is just a
basic overview there are lots of other little
things that might come up when you're trying
to optimize a lipstick formula the listing
might stick to the mold when it's being made
and so you might need to add something that helps
it shrink a little bit as it hardens and so that
unsticks it from the mold you might also need
pigment dispersers to make the color more even
so the other question is what lipstick am i
wearing the lipstick i'm wearing when people
usually ask me about what lipstick i'm wearing
is this one it's a pretty old lipstick from teeez
cosmetics it's from eve's ready to wear collection
and it's called classy caramel this is a really
pretty brick color it's super moisturizing and
it glides on really well it's been discontinued
for a long time and i know it's kind of gross but
i still use it but in my defense this is based on
ingredients that don't go rancid easily there
are lots of hydrocarbons which are very i guess
unnatural and on the bright side it means that it
lasts for ages without having serious rancidity or
microbe problems the other reason i'm still using
it is because it's really hard to find a really
moisturizing lipstick and it's really hard to find
this sort of brick color anymore apparently a lot
of lipstick brands have been discontinuing brick
colors because they're a bit dated and 90s but i
think it looks really good i'm not really good at
following trends but from the fact that everyone's
been asking me about it i think the demand is
still there so please can we have some more
so in the interest of recommending a lipstick
that other people could get and the fact that
i should probably replace it i went around to
a whole bunch of stores to try to find a dupe
i think i might have swatched like a hundred
lipsticks that look like they could be a dupe
but i only managed to find two conveniently one
is kinda high-end and one is budget-friendly
the first one is becca ultimate lipstick love
in rouge this is a really nice creamy opaque
formula and it comes in a really nice luxe
tube which gives a satisfying sound when you
open it and it clicks in nicely with a magnet
this is a bit less moisturizing and doesn't
apply as smoothly but it's really pigmented and
leaves a pretty even stain after it wears off
the other lipstick that match really well is
revlon super lustrous lipstick in extra spicy
revlon are my favorite drugstore lipstick brand
i just find that the formulas are really nice
and really even and they're just really easy
to use this is more moisturizing than the
becca lipstick but less pigmented it's sort
of in between the becca and teeez lipsticks
these aren't quite as moisturizing and glossy
as the teeez cosmetics one so sometimes when i
wear them i put on an extra glossier lipstick on
top i've been using revlon super lustrous glass
shine in rum raisin this is a really moisturizing
lipstick it's almost like a lip balm but the color
isn't quite as intense and so if i'm trying to go
for a more opaque lipstick look i layer that on
top of something else on its own it's really good
for casual wear if you just want something that
gives a bit of color without being a full lipstick
it's a lot like revlon's discontinued lip butters
some of the sales assistants recommended that i
go to mac because mac tends to do nice 90s colors
but they didn't actually have a good match mac
chili is the same color but matte and so that
doesn't give the same sort of finish the same
sort of easy application as my teeez cosmetics
one we did find that using good form over auburn
lipliner gave the same sort of effect but i prefer
a more all-in-one lipstick that's easy to
reapply so i guess i'm still looking for
the perfect dupe of this lipstick if you have
any suggestions leave them in the comments and
i'll try to track them down and compare them
i hope you like this video it's a little bit
different from the usual skin care content
but i hope it was still really interesting
click the like subscribe check me out
on instagram and check out my blog if
you like nerding out about beauty and i'll
see you next time for more beauty science